icebergs can be some of the most
beautiful things in the world but they
can also be very dangerous
good one of our team members with a lot
of experience in polar regions tells me
that there is an iceberg that looks
pretty stable so we should go and dive
there we get in the zodiac and we'll
jump in the water with a group of
microbiology and our filmmakers
I'm on the zodiac getting ready for
jumping in the water and all of a sudden
I hear I'm really loud cry at the same
time everybody comes out of the water at
the end of the dive I see the iceberg
starting to move and then I yell
everybody get out of the water get out
get out get out get out get out and they
didn't know what was going on and within
30 seconds the eyes were turned upside
down
and if our team had taken I mean and
longer to get out of the water something
really bad could have happened
there have always been icebergs in the
polar regions but now because of the
warmer temperatures because of climate
change the glaciers are calving
more and more and more which means that
there are many more icebergs I got out
immediately I lost you guys and I was
like this is yeah and if we lit up it at
2 there we would get serious
oh the dude
a little too close that was crazy
thanks for diving I may be over ice God
it just started raining down on top of
me my initial reaction was to just
scream in my own head